[Music]
okay today it's all about clean fresh
zingy flavors and speed a few years ago
I traveled around Cambodia Thailand
Vietnam and Malaysia learning all I
could from the chefs over there and I
really fell in love with all their food
I brought back those influences to my
home kitchen and I've been incorporating
them into my cooking ever since so get
ready for some cracking recipes here on
my ultimate Southeast Asian dishes
if you want a pick-me-up first thing in
the morning forget a double espresso I
think chili gives you an even bigger
boost and it's incredible in my
breakfast fruit salad
for lunch it's my take on a traditional
noodle soup with fresh clams for dessert
banana fritters bursting with flavor and
one of the best things about Southeast
Asian food is it's easy and a great way
to get your kids cooking Jack to prove
it my son Jack's joining me in the
kitchen to cook up some sticky spicy
chicken wings because it's your favorite
so with fragrant Thai rice and stir-fry
green beans with soy and peanut dressing
this is my ultimate Southeast Asian food
breakfast lunch and dinner
foreign
fruit salad and it's for breakfast would
you believe start off with a chili now
give it a little rub
so
you can hear those seeds being released
get your knife
and come all the way down
turn it over and just slice it
into four and then
finely chop that chili
I want this salad slightly hot
so I'm going to use all the chili about
half the seeds the seeds are where the
heat is so the less you use the milder
your dish nicely chopped
next
one of my favorite Pace Tamarind paste
this is quite tart quite sour but it's a
wonderful complement to the sweetness of
the fruit and it goes brilliantly well
with a chili palm sugar
and this is where it sweetens up
the dressing because it enriches it then
the zest and the juice of a lime cut
into quarters
and then twist the line so you maximize
and all that juice out now to finish
that dressing off some toasted peanuts
pan nice and hot
a little touch of salt
that'll help dry roast the peanuts even
quicker
make sure you get really nice dark color
on those peanuts because it will really
transform that dressing
to crush your roasted nuts the mess free
way simply wrap them in a clean cloth
and use a rolling pin or a pan to bash
them
Crush
that's the hard bit done
now for the fruit and here's an easy way
to prep a pineapple pineapple
take off the top
take off the bottom
and stand it up use a cornery knife
and follow down
basically like shaving the pineapple
don't worry about these little spikes
there
the secret behind doing it this way is
not losing half the pineapple there's
nothing wrong with a few Brown bits it's
all good fiber
slice the pineapple in half
and then slice down
each quarter slice across and chop
delicious
pineapple chunks
next apples and pears diced then to give
a lovely fresh Light note the seeded
cucumber I don't want the seeds in the
fruit salad the cucumber seeds will make
it very watery and
dilute the strength for that wonderful
chilling there cucumber in for some
sweetness
delicious mango this slice it nicely
that you're dressing and just drizzle
that over the fruit salad in
a cigarette of a good fruit salad
it's not drowning in the dressing but
really make sure that you've got that
nice coating on all the fruits
don't worry about just having for
breakfast because this is the kind of
Tangy fruit salad you can have for lunch
a healthy snack in the afternoon but it
transforms a traditional fruit salad
into something really delicious
spicy fruit salad with a kickoff chili
trust me it's an incredible breakfast
and a guaranteed pick me up in the
morning
[Music]
next I'm showing you a sensational
Southeast Asian lunch and dinner
here's a closer look at some of the key
ingredients you'll need to buy to make
them
first up a Southeast Asian essential
lemongrass buy it as a paste dry or
powdered but I love it fresh best
most of the flavor is in the thick Bowl
band which can be either crushed or
chopped to add flavor to a dish wrapped
in Kling film it will keep up to 10 days
in the fridge
lemongrass is Central to Southeast Asian
Foods especially Thai and I'm using it
in my lunch and dinner recipes
[Music]
another Southeast Asian staple is
tamarind made from the fruit from The
Tamarind Tree biting powder cake or
paste form it's sweet and sour at the
same time and gives Brown sauces and
Worcestershire sauce their distinct
flavors
I've already used it in my fruit salad
now I'm going to put it in my chicken
marinade for dinner too
[Applause]
lastly is clams
their prized from all over southeast
Asia but the most common types to buy in
Britain are beautiful plump Venus clams
sweet tasty middle of the clams and
razor clams which are shaped like an
old-fashioned Cutthroat razor clams are
fantastic raw bait in sauces or in soups
like this one I'm making for lunch
there's one rule only prepare live ones
so discard any that don't open during
cooking
[Applause]
[Music]
all over southeast Asia you find people
cooking and eating the huge bowls of
delicious noodle soups it's a very
simple dish but the variations you get
are extraordinary different Meats
different fish and even different
dumplings but what I love most about
noodle soup is the fact that it's a
complete Meal carbs protein and
vegetables in one big bowl of happiness
for my ultimate Southeast Asian lunch
I'm showing you one of my favorites the
spicy clamor noodle soup followed by
sweet Moorish banana and coconut
fritters for dessert
first up my dessert banana fritters
take your bananas
and to get them really nice and soft
just rub
banana sip together flour and baking
powder
sugar into the flour
then add coconut for texture and a pinch
of salt
sounds strange in the dessert but it
works brilliantly especially with the
fritters makes the batter nice and crisp
start crushing
foreign
of the fork and just push it against the
side of the bowl
and then
once you mix that through
make that mix now slightly fragrant with
some lime zest
now
the lime
just really elevates the sort of
richness and the denseness of the banana
a couple of slim fill so it doesn't get
a skin on top set that in the fridge for
15 minutes
as the banana fruit and mixture rests
I'm getting on with my broth for the
noodle and clam soup
fish sauce is the base
bring that up to the boil now to take
that broth to another level
in with chopped shallots fresh ginger
and a whole chili seeds and all I
actually quite like it spicy
just
chop once and into the broth
bring up the ball and let it simmer
Gallagher it's a sort of
almost like a softer version of Ginger
slightly Milder
you can use galangal paste but I prefer
the fresh stuff the stems for coriander
we'll finish the broth with the
heads and that's what endeared me to the
Southeast Asian style of cooking
across my travels there was there's no
waste in
lime leaves
for me
one of my favorites incredibly pungent
Strong full of flavor very acidic but
gives a really nice Aroma to the broth
just tear them
and now the lemongrass
so the secret here that's where all the
flavor is right at the very end so you
take the back of the knife and you just
bash the lemongrass
it's all that flavor it's going to run
out in seconds that's the base
of the broth down the longer you leave
it the more intense it gets whilst the
broth infuses soak your rice noodles in
boiling water for 10 minutes just enough
time to fry your fritters the batter now
is ready
use a metal spoon to drop the batter to
the bottom of the pan
I'm going to hit that oil they puff up
that's why it's important to put your
spoon into the oil so the mixture runs
off
it creates this lovely little fritter
and then gently
fry get a slotted spoon and nice and
carefully turn them over
smell of that lime is extraordinary
fry for two to three minutes
as they start floating
it signifies the fact that they're
cooked
off with a gas
and just let them drained are those
Beauties lovely
sprinkling when they're hot with sugar
actually sticks them
they're done ready to go the last job
before serving the clams never be scared
of cooking shellfish the most important
rule is if they are slightly opened a
millimeter discarded make sure mussels
clams are always tight cook the clams
for just three to five minutes or until
they're all open
bring that up to the boil and this is
where we finish the broth
touch up
fish sauce a little sprinkle of sugar
drain your noodles
into the bowl
added texture
some delicious bean sprouts
get your lime
fresh squeeze and lime juice in
beautiful
literally as the stock comes up to the
boil the clams open automatically
so they cut beautifully the flavor from
inside the clam has enhanced the broth
smell is incredible
the clams cooked finished with fresh
coriander and serve there you have
perfect lunch
a delicious spicy clam noodle
with an amazing banana fritter
my spicy clam noodle soup and banana and
coconut fritters made in minutes and
proof you only need to travel as far as
your kitchen to get the taste of
Southeast Asia
foreign
southeast Asia one of the things that
really struck me was how seriously they
take meal times family and friends all
sit down together to eat catch up and
have a great time it's a really big part
of their daily life so how it works is
they put a whole load of different
dishes in the middle of the table and
everyone helps themselves I love this
way of eating it's very social and
really relaxed so I've adopted it here
in our house too
I also like the family to share the
cooking
[Music]
and today my son Jack's joining me in
the kitchen he's got a vested interest
in learning to cook sticky spiced
chicken wings
Jack
give us a hand please Bob
why
because it's your favorites yeah chicken
wings okay all right let's start off
with the marinade Tamarind paste him
first
all that into there all of that yeah all
of that okay
so two tablespoons of palm sugar please
heated sugar and there's a really good
question there is it's a natural palm
sugar and it's perfect for marinades how
many wings you think you've eaten so far
at the age of 13. oh well I eat probably
50 a year 50 a year yeah something like
that a nice sprinkle of chili flakes
depends how hot you like them oh I love
them hot hot uh don't forget the girls
you know they start complaining when you
get them too hot
come you love hot food
um I don't know I truly love hot food so
in there we've got palm sugar
Tamarind paste chili flakes
some garlic one nice tablespoon
fish sauce please check which is looking
really good isn't it and then a couple
tablespoons of oil for marinade
in
a nice little taste
not your finger jack
ET
that's really good right Wings in get
your hands in there and start rubbing in
the marinade please okay so the secret
now is to coat
the chicken wings and all that marinade
yeah yeah
how long do you leave them in here do
you want the longer the better
cover that
Glenn film
excellent
good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going
[Applause]
all right so they've marinated now
if you take the trail please look
on one thank you and then we're gonna
put some tin foil on there thank you
so
pour that in half
it stops them from sticking and that'll
stop
the wings from burning so from there get
them really dipped in that marinade and
try and get the wing like that and just
sort of scoop it
no like that to get that really nice
glaze on there
and then just
yeah
it's all like garlic will roast
and we've got all those wings
beautifully
done okay mate then ready for the oven
170 25 to 30 minutes
good man
excellent
nice it's hot wings are in
right
to go with my ultimate Southeast Asian
dinner rice cooked in homemade Thai
green curry paste for the easy green
curry paste roughly chopped coriander
lemongrass
green chilies
Lime Leaf shallots
garlic and ginger
a lug of oil and Blitz
the paste takes minutes to make but it
will keep for up to 10 days if covered
with oil and stored in a sealed jar in
the fridge
to awaken the flavors lime roll to
release the juice
next season with salt and pepper and
blend into a smooth paste
keep the pace until aromatic
adding cooled or leftover rice I love
using fragrant jasmine rice but your
standard long grain rice is great too
when thoroughly heated through serve
Thai green curry paste is so easy to
make so with rice like this it's
incredible but simply add to chicken
fish or veg to create a fantastic meal
in minutes
right now for the green beans
beans in
bring the water up the ball what's the
first thing I should put in there beans
salt salt so nice pinch of salt in there
yeah so make an amazing dressing two
nice tablespoons yep a bit crunchy
peanut butter please why is it crunchy
I'll give it texture and it'll be nice
and sort of chunky green beans in okay
got the rice the green beans
we're gonna blast them for two two and a
half minutes what does blanching
actually mean blanching means sort of
Park cooking
okay I'm gonna blanch them in boiling
water yeah and then finish them in the
pan use the back of the spoon will be a
little bit easier
a teaspoon of brown sugar and she goes
nice
is that a little bit too thick maybe
yeah it is let's put a little touch more
soy sauce in there let it down
yeah yeah a little touch of vinegar nice
I'll get a pan on now for my beans
so a little taste do you taste it
it's so good oh man
hmm wow so have you got the garlic like
that and just slice the garlic down like
this
keep the knife nice and flat and that
way you'll slice through it
'll take your time don't worry about the
speed and technique right first just cut
it in half okay
your fingers good and then lay the flat
side down so it's nice and sturdy and
that nail there
it's not out like that it's just guiding
the knife so you can never cut yourself
like that
good I'll drain the beans
nice A little tablespoon of oil
put the pan nice and hot
it's for the garlic and people
okay
nice
smell that already
so give that
a little toss so when you toss it push
it down
push away and pull back
okay have a little go
push it down and gently that's it take
your time
nice
so push down and pull back up that's it
nice so it's getting nice and golden
brown green beans are drained
and they go in now to the garlic
combination of green beans
okay with the rice
and this one of that
oh wow I want you now to spoon the
dressing with these and she goes nice
how delicious does that look
wow what's Daddy's policy at home no
waste no waste no waste bud
now
smell that now
oh wow it doesn't smell like green beans
oh thanks
how nice is that lovely amazing right
that's the rice that's the green beans
[Music]
no I want you to sprinkle some toasted
sesame seeds on top please
nice and generous for the sesame seed
I'll give the beans a little bit of a
crunch
now
all that's left for your favorites to
come out
don't those beans smell amazing yeah
um Jack look at those Beauties one for
me
one for you three for me one for you
I like to sprinkle some spring onions
on top please
nice and generous you've transformed a
very cheap and cheersful chicken wing
yeah right and take them over please do
not drop them nice
this is my ultimate simple Southeast
Asian dinner sticky spicy chicken wings
Thai green curry rice and fantastic
beans with chili peanut dressing
guaranteed to get the fussies of eaters
into greens
Holly Tana ready for Jack's Wings hole's
gonna have himself and pass them along
chat with some mice guys
I know you're allergic to anything green
how are the beans
I've seen you eat more green beans the
last five minutes they have them the
last 10 years
now I know the secret you have to put
peanut butter
fingers right definitely
oh wow nice very very good very nice
Jack yeah they're tasty red there's no
dainty way of doing this no Holly don't
worry about your nail varnish you'll be
fine
you're such a lady
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
starting out as a young Chef my biggest
influence was definitely French cuisine
and when I was 23 years of age I was
determined to learn as much as I could
so I set off for Paris to work in some
of the most demanding and exacting
kitchens in the world and my passion and
love for French food really took hold
first up for breakfast a French
Patisserie delicacy Madeleine's those
shells of a light sponge flavored with
lemon and poppy seed for lunch my take
on a French classic the salad nicoise
with a gutsy Caper and anchovy dressing
accompanied by delicious pear and creamy
goat cheese Tartine
utility and my youngest Tilly gets a
taste for French cooking as we create
chicken fricassee
so with Herbie sauteed potatoes followed
by lavender creme caramel this is my
ultimate French food breakfast lunch and
dinner my ultimate French breakfast
isn't complex or flashy it's just simple
elegant and delicious
the secret to a really good Madeleine is
it's light fluffy delicious and it's
perfect
with the coffee in the morning so melt
the butter gently next
three eggs
[Music]
that was one of the most exciting things
about living in Paris there was always
something there and that little pastry
shop that used to live above I'm gonna
incorporate the sugar
and then give that a really good whisk
because it's important to incorporate
some air now the secret to whisking is a
big beautiful balloon whisk
the bigger the balloon whisk the more
aeration you'll get in the mixture so
the best thing to do
is just go from left to right and then
change hands
every 15 or 20 seconds
so your hands never get tired and tilt
the ball to your advantage as well
now you can see the mixture starting to
aerate
it's almost double in size
[Music]
the more you whisk this the lighter it
becomes
so it starts to almost look like a light
whipped cream
gone as that dark Rich egg yolk color
beautiful
once the eggs and sugar become pale
creamy and thick sift in the
self-raising flour
serving the flour
now I'm giving my madeleines a Twist by
adding poppy seeds for a crunch and
lemon for flavor a zest of a lemon in
there
generous on the lemon
lime is wonderful
orange zest again beautiful I've even
made pink grapefruit madeleines with
poppy seeds delicious but lemon for me
is the best
pour the melted butter down the side of
the bowl
so it cools down even more and then
combine start mixing that in it's really
important at this stage that we don't
beat
the mixture I want to keep that nice
aerated texture across the Madeleine mix
so I'm going to use a spatula now and
just gently mix my butter in
now give that a good mix
and they say that the longer you make
the mix up in advance
the higher they raise in the oven
look at that it looks beautiful leave
that to sit there
[Music]
and we'll butter and line our molds
you can make these in little miniature
Yorkshire pudding molds I've even seen
Madeleine's been cooked in espresso cups
so if you haven't got the traditional
Madeleine tray Yorkshire pudding trays
are just as good lightly butter
the inside of the tray take a tablespoon
of flour
and the secret now is to lie in the mold
with the flour that stops any chance the
Madeleine is sticking
tap the sieve
into all the little grooves
and this will ensure that they'll come
out instantly
then all you do then is just stand up
the tray and tap it two or three times
and you'll see the flower roll out
so there you go
the baking sheet lined beautifully no
excess butter and no excess flour the
beauty of this recipe is that you can
make it the night before and then simply
bake it in the morning
when you're ready to go put the mixture
into a jug to make it really easy to
pour into the tin
give it a little stir
so you've got that nice even
distribution of those poppy seeds and
just gently
lovely
firm up to the top oh beautiful
so much easier pouring this from a jug
because you get the exact amount in into
the oven 180 degrees do not open that
door before 10 minutes
and wait for that wonderful surprise
[Music]
they smell amazing
now
a little tap on the side of the tray
once you just all pop out it's usually
done
that smell is unique
that nice soft
crisp outside with this lovely fragrant
fluffy Center
and the secret of a great Madeleine
as the French would swear by it there's
this lovely little Mound on top
they call it the nipple
but
that is the confirmation that is perfect
my poppy and lemon madeleines are a
sophisticated content will start to the
day and take me straight back to Paris
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you a
fantastic French inspired lunch and
dinner
[Music]
but first here's a look at some of the
key ingredients you'll need to add a bit
of garlic Flair to your cooking
[Music]
the one ingredient most associated with
French food is garlic and it's no
surprise almost every one of my French
recipes has it in
[Music]
garlic is a member of the allium or
onion family and comes in all shapes and
sizes and strengths Pink garlic from
Little Trek in Southwest France is
considered the finest with a strong
sweet taste
elephant garlic has massive bulbs and a
much milder flavor but today I'm using a
common white type you get in all the
supermarkets it's a great all-rounder
[Music]
Brandy really is the ultimate Spirit of
France it's made from either distilled
grapes or fruit
armenyak from gascony in the Southwest
is made from wine distilled in Oak casks
and it's the oldest recorded Brandy in
France
cognacs also are wine Brandy named after
town in Portugal region in the west
where it must be made to be classified
as cognac
Calvados is an apple brandy made from
distilled cider and comes from Normandy
French cooked with Brandy a lot and tend
to ignite or flombe it to bring amazing
depth of flavor to dishes like the
chicken fricassee I'm serving for dinner
France is justifiably famous for his
cheeses and one of my favorites is Ghost
cheese
called Chev in French they produce
hundreds of types from the very mild and
creamy to the strong and pungent and
because it's so delicious the French
keep most of it for themselves and only
export a tiny amount luxurious soft
ghost cheese goes perfectly well with
sweet pears and earthy walnuts in the
open sandwich I'm making for lunch
when I was living in France I got to
know two very distinct traditions of
French food on the one hand there was
the delicious oat Cuisine I cooked all
day in the restaurant and on the other
hand there was the food you ate in
people's homes which is a lot simpler to
make but still absolutely delicious
My ultimate French inspired lunch it's
very light bright and really takes me
back to when I lived in Paris
it's my take on the salad misoise served
with a delicious goat cheese and pear
Tartine
think of the nisoise as an assembly job
of delicious ingredients brought
together with a fantastic dressing the
secret behind mine salad niswas is in
the dressing
spoon Dijon mustard into a pestle and
mortar some people top the salad with
Anchovies and capers but in mine they're
the base to the dressing we're going to
grind that to a paste
and then get the garlic in there season
well with black pepper
quickly
it doesn't need any salt in there
because of the anchovies add a couple
tablespoons of red wine vinegar olive
oil and lastly flat leaf parsley to give
the dressing freshness against those
deep flavors they say thick Rich
substantial dressing dressing done now
for the salad ball potatoes green beans
and eggs from a rolling ball seven and a
half to eight minutes and should keep
that nice yolky creamy texture in the
center once the eggs are ready put them
into cold water to Salt them cooking and
this is a great trick to peel them so
much easier peeling eggs when you use
the water
but they've been cooling down in and the
water will seep underneath all the shell
and so the whole shell just gets peeled
off of one beautiful big layer
now beans
nice and crunchy season the beans and
potatoes whilst they're still warm so
they absorb more flavor a little drizzle
of olive oil salt pepper
and just let them sit there
whilst the potatoes and beans cool down
I'm doing a simple French Open sandwich
which is called a Tartine
it's a delicious
first I'm toasting baguette on the
griddle
lightly oil
a griddle pan get your bread
stick it on there
take a pair
it goes brilliantly well with goat's
cheese slice the pear into finger width
pieces
the color we're looking for that dark
crispy texture now for the ghost cheese
give it a season it doesn't need salt
because little Fresco's cheese is
already quite salty then a handful of
crumbled walnuts
they go under the grill whilst I put the
tuning these ones together
my secret to assembling a great nicoise
salad is the start of the middle of the
plate and add ingredients layer by layer
so there's one thing I'm always missing
the bottom of salad is dressing so I
like to put it on the plate first baby
gem lettuce is great because it's robust
and holds that heavy dressing then add
firm waxy salad potatoes and green beans
I like them to have a bit of a crunch
canned tuna can be fantastic I'm using a
good quality one in olive oil which has
been drained next baby plum tomatoes
which have a lovely intense sweet flavor
and then my eggs that nice dark Rich
yolk useful
[Music]
yogurt's still creamy
inside
he's a little Olive nicoise this will
work just as well with other black
olives and then your dressing
drizzle that round gently beautiful
as a nisswas in heaven now Tartine
wow just a smell
of those grilled walnuts
that is beautiful
a simple but very elegant
tuna nisswas
but delicious goat's cheese sandwich
[Music]
my vibrant and gutsy Nisswa salad with
that incredible anchovy and Caper
dressing so with a pear and ghost cheese
Tartine too good to let the French keep
it all to themselves
[Music]
in general I think it's pretty fair to
say that whether they're rich or poor
the French are a nation of food
obsessives and one of the biggest
lessons I absorb when I was over there
was the central importance of great
ingredients
not the only one in my family who loves
French food
joining me in the kitchen today is my
youngest daughter Tilly who adores it
made with fantastic chicken cooked using
a classic but simple French technique
this is my ultimate home-cooked French
dinner first chop my chicken fricassee
Tilly
do you mind helping daddy with the
chicken fricassee please
we're going to start off with Browning
oh
the chicken off nicely pan on get that
nice and hot what I want you to do for
me first is to season
chicken with salt and pepper please
thank you so that's on one side then we
turn the chicken over
so we season it on the other side
salt good girl and pepper nice
now this is almost like a chicken stew
okay what's that there
[Music]
Thai time good girl what's that one
there
that's right Rosemary
and because this is quite a rustic
French dish we don't need to chop
everything so you get the garlic
and you just smash it like that now
smell
that's right
so that's nice and hot put a tablespoon
of olive oil in there a couple of gloves
one two good girl put the chicken in
it and you lay away
you've got that nice and brown getting
good at this you are
inside down so we get the color on the
skin now I just want you to cut the
mushrooms in half the belly please okay
these are Chestnut mushrooms there are
lots of different types of mushrooms out
there there are lots and lots of
different types of mushrooms which one's
your favorite one of my favorites is the
giron mushroom I like mushrooms that are
a bit bigger than this and
um some dinners with mum we cut out the
middle put pesto and cheese in it and
then we bake them oh so I want you to
sprinkle the pancetta over the chicken
please
here we go nice the machine did not yet
because I'm gonna get some color on the
chicken first
okay
and as that pancetta
started to cook down to put a really
nice flavor on the chicken yeah yeah so
we're sort of soaking everything okay
like garlic in please good girl just
throw them in
and I want you to sprinkle the mushrooms
on top of that good girl
and then there's a rosemary okay you get
your fingers like that and you pull it
down you take it all off
hold it
put it down good cow so now you've got
the nice little Rosemary sprigs and we
do the same with the thyme now the thyme
flower is a little bit smaller what
different flavors do they give so the
thyme is a little bit sweeter okay and
the rosary a little bit more Savory
which ones you like I like them both
because they both give a nice smell
don't they so they Leaf in
I'd like you to put that Rosemary and
Thyme in there please
lovely sprinkle over right I'd like you
to stand back now because we're going to
flambe this I do not want to get those
little slippers caught on fire what are
their names
and Judith Judith nice okay great ready
yeah him with a brandy
and then just tilt the pan gently
[Music]
whoa whoa how cool is that
beautiful a bit like a cauldron oh the
cognac has been flambe so there's no raw
alcohol anywhere so we've got a really
nice deep rich flavor I'm gonna add my
chicken stock you know Rumple likes that
not my slipper
ah Rumple the dog well he likes chicken
stock yes when he's a good boy he gets
him he gets it in his um with his
biscuit it's gone and like wow really
quickly simmer and reduce the stock for
around 10 minutes now we're going to
cook the most amazing potatoes
so do potatoes are really simple to make
and absolutely delicious start by
slicing the potatoes into finger whipped
pieces then parboil them for five to six
minutes
when you cook something like Rosemary or
thyme or basil does it slowly let off
the flavor into the hot oil very much so
pan add a tablespoon of goose fat and
saute the potatoes until they turn
golden
and add in shallots garlic Rosemary and
Thyme that goes in
over top
and that goose fat now is starting to
fry the potatoes you just leave that sap
there
to complete my ultimate French dinner my
version of a classic a glorious lavender
creme caramel for dessert
the first job is the lavender sugar you
can buy this ready-made or simply add
dried edible sprigs of lavender to
caster sugar and store you can also try
this trick with vanilla pods and
cinnamon to bring new subtle flavors to
sweets and bacon
[Music]
for the creme caramel melt plain caster
sugar until it turns dark golden
pour into ramekins sprinkle with
lavender flowers and cool
now to make a simple custard gently heat
whole milk in a pan until steaming
meanwhile whisk together egg vanilla
seeds and lavender sugar until golden
and fluffy then gradually pour the hot
milk into the mix whisking continuously
until the custard is smooth and creamy
set cook in a water bath or bammari a
good tip is to line a roasting tin with
a cloth to stop the ramekins jiggling
around pour your custard
then boiling water around the ramekins
until halfway up the sides then cook in
a preheated oven for around 30 minutes
until set
cool in the fridge then when you're
ready to serve dip the ramekins in hot
water to loosen the creme caramel
[Music]
caramel
foreign
look at that chicken now
so I'm just going to turn the gas right
down
and put the lid on
just like that but leave a little bit so
it can let out some stuff so I can let
out some steam that's right
now what I'd like to do is to chop Deli
some parsley crunch it up nicely tuck
your fingers in and take your time
[Music]
now my hands have got lots of different
names they've got all those wonderful
flavors you could almost be French
sprinkle it on there
good girl
nice
messy bookoo
nice
no potatoes of chicken I can tell Jack's
gonna love this is he looks delish
doesn't it
before you took the lid off let's get on
my darling good job by the way thank you
I can't wait for the others to try it I
hope they love it this is my ultimate
French dinner chicken fricassee with
Sensational Herbie soda potatoes and
lavender creme caramel
[Music]
mom and Holly oh so nice doesn't it
no Daddy who's the one that burnt the
garlic what
could you dad
trust you to find that Jack potatoes
he'll eat like these ones
oh no way
potatoes I love burnt garlic
Bon Appetit and look out for the burnt
garlic it was supposed to be crispy but
you've known the difference between
crispy and burnt do you know what I
think your daughter might take off to
you
hi sous chef cheers there are loads more
great home cooking recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the App
Store good luck
[Applause]
[Music]